the jurgen experience to me yes it's so
funny to imagine that any company is
letting me advertise for them
something and that makes me feel gleeful
when i'm doing it and it's cool that
most of them are cool with
it is so fun it's so fun it's like
clearly just fun
yeah and this is delicious this is so
good man
so good
but you know man like musk
he's finally doing the thing
if i were a billionaire for sure it's
like oh i'll just buy twitter can i buy
twitter let's see what happens he
doesn't care i think he does care do you
think he cares i can't tell he does
genuinely he's concerned about
censorship freedom of speech yes he's
very he said freedom of speech is
someone you don't like excuse me freedom
of speech is someone you don't like
saying something you don't want to hear
he goes they have to have that right
yeah it's essential to a democracy yeah
most people objectively agree the
problem is you get scared because they
see how
like mobs of people can move in a very
negative direction right i think people
if there's a real concern like i am in
no way supporting censorship clearly
right
absolutely the opposite but i understand
why people are concerned about large
groups of people being really shitty
and all right and getting on the social
media platforms that they've done
they've done this um
campaign over the last few years to like
silence certain voices stop aggressive
people stop people being shitty to
people okay and yeah isn't some some of
that is good right sure like doc stop
doxxing stop people are threatening
people stop people who are harassing
people but it's like where does it end
and how do you know you don't that's
where that's where it's [ __ ] weird
because if you just let
wild free speech like there's going to
be a but like there's a bunch of people
on like 4chan and those kind of places
and they're saying stuff just for fun
right because nobody knows who they are
and they can just say it and they don't
[ __ ] mean it yeah they're saying
because it's a crazy thing to say if
you're at work in a job you hate sitting
in your cubicle and you decide to make a
frog with a nazi outfit on and it
doesn't mean you're a real nazi and it
doesn't mean it's in the word anyway
it's edge lord edge lording it's an edge
lord those people
are
they're confined to small corners of the
internet right now
and if
if you just let them loose
if you let the frog people loose yeah
like you remember the frog people during
the trunk the trump campaign yeah of
course they took over the frog the frog
guy the guy was so
he's very cool what did he say
just what you're what the [ __ ] the frog
was never a nazi the frog was like funny
and sweet was he upset that he took his
frog yeah it was just
i think it would be a little bit like
the first person who had the hitler
mustache wow you know what i mean like
imagine and then hitler sees it and he's
like god that's [ __ ] cool i'm gonna
start having a mustache like that you're
like no
it's like that but also
you know i don't i don't know how many
people know that like the
they discovered an egyptian god and
again this could all be trolling
keck the god of chaos who happens to be
a frog so yeah what was what so within
that whatever that was an actual like
chaos magic was being they were calling
it meme magic or whatever but they were
all they were
like actively doing chaos magic and a
lot of their rituals seem to have worked
to some degree so yeah i know you mean
like
the
the the quest like the question
is
in a world where
we don't even know how many of these
people are human
who are writing [ __ ] on twitter or
wherever look at what gpt what is it
three or two the ai that like completely
imitates human beings like have you ever
gone to the explain how that works so
it's a neural network that can be
programmed to different personalities
that can imitate
human speech well enough that they can
leave messages and you don't know
for sure if it's a human or not wow so
if you go to on reddit there's a
subreddit which is
the ai bots arguing with each other oh
my god on the reddit and like once i
left that up
and i remember i was just reading it
thinking i was on the front page of
reddit and getting really engaged and
the arguments these bots were having
with each other it's that convincing so
the the freedom of speech thing runs
into
okay of course it's like a no-brainer
humanist ideal human should be able to
say whatever they want this is this is
like
the most important way that we we must
have some kind of debate or discourse
where one person is allowed to be a
complete [ __ ] right and not because
we want [ __ ] because hopefully in
the discussion
some bit of truth will sink
down into their consciousness and they
will grow as a person that i think
that's what their roots is that's the
hope that's the hope but what is what if
the person is a robot
uh is an ai
device that is being
made to have certain personalities that
represent demographics that you're
trying to manipulate is a corporation or
a state or whatever at that point
is it freedom of speech are bots allowed
to have freedom of speech this is this
is the uh
what i one of the things musk was saying
he might do with twitter which i think
is brilliant
anyone can get the stupid blue check
mark you pay for it and you have to
verify yourself so that like you're we
know you're a real person right meaning
that it would be too expensive for the
bot swarms to function it would it would
go from being
like if you have a blue check mark
whatever you're something or whatever
too if you don't have a blue check mark
you're probably a bot and so then we
eliminate all the ai all the [ __ ]
state-sponsored
shills all the people who've spent years
and years and years building these fake
identities online like they're like uh
farming personalities
because you know in the old days
somebody tweets some [ __ ] and you're
like what the [ __ ] is that and you go
and look at their account and it's like
three days old so it has less
credibility but they've been growing
these personalities
for years so you go and look at their
tweets and it kind of looks like a
person mixed in with their interminable
tweets about some political issue
like only an insane person every three
minutes tweeting something or like went
to the pool with dairy today you know
what i mean in some weird distant
picture of a pool so it kind of seems
like a real person anyway the point is
the freedom of speech issue
is uh right now we're running into the
problem of brand new technologies that
aren't even human that are being
designed to influence public discourse
in a way that's going to push the needle
towards whatever it is right whatever
your laws your corporation wants
whatever some the state wants and we
know for sure they're being implemented
that way [ __ ] yeah these bot swarms they
found what they found uh
in the ukraine they found like one of
these like
creepy shells
of phones it's just phones oh i've seen
those but i didn't know they were
running an ai i thought like people were
manually typing in messages because i
know they were doing that first i think
both both i mean both things are
happening like
you know
it's a pr firm basically you know
politicians have publicists too isn't it
wild though that that's the best way to
defeat america
is to get people separate from each
other arguing with with each other and
lose all faith in the democratic process
yeah sure all faith in democracy lose
all faith powerful weapon man it's like
it's amazing we
dropped
an atom bomb
multiple times on cities filled with
people the united states did that
everyone knows that
so our karma
we've got some [ __ ] up karma man
you know what i mean so so like that so
the problem with these atom bombs
biggest problem with atom bomb
is i mean aside from the fact that it
kills random people and is is horrible
it irradiates the it irradiates the
ground the buildings so you so there's
no plundering to be had if you you
traditional war you plunder whether you
however you want to make it look you're
plundering if i nuke you i can no longer
plunder so this is why biological
weapons popped like are desirable
because then it burns out the biome in
the area wait a little bit and then you
can go plunder but even better than that
get into the [ __ ]
minds of the people in the country that
you want to invade and then just change
their minds so that the country shifts
into what you wanted that country to be
now you didn't even have to do anything
except they're yours they're believing
in you and then in that the country
starts falling apart the cia by the way
this is one of the things they do they
go into other countries they cause like
disturbances and then it collapses i
mean it's a classic weapon of war so
anyway yeah i obviously we might be the
entire united states and probably other
countries might
currently
be
irradiated not by like obviously
radiation but by bad data created by
artificial intelligence bots that have
been programmed to swarm social media
and give the impression that there was
some like something happening that
wasn't even happening at all